[Applaudissements]
nous voyons depuis des centaines
d'années que les noirs et les gens de
couleur sont absolument maltraités et
tués dans les rues et ça ne fait
qu'empirer
nous en avons assez et s'ils ne veulent
pas écouter nous allons crier de plus en
plus fort et nous n'allons pas arrêter
tant que quelque chose ne sera pas fait
nous en avons assez
ces gens en ont assez il est temps de
faire quelques changements
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ils vont me tuer
ils vont me tuer je ne peux pas respirer
je ne peux pas respirer s'il vous plaît
monsieur s'il vous plaît s'il vous plaît
s'il vous plaît je ne peux pas respirer
je promets que mes futurs bébés noirs ne
mourront pas parce que je n'en ai pas
fait assez
parce que j'ai passé plus de temps à
pleurer à me plaindre et un poster que
je n'ai fait de vraies actions
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tout est écrit